Hello, everyone. Welcome to a new episode of The
Dissenter. I'm your host, as always, Ricardo Lops, and
today I'm joined by Doctors James Tilley and Sarah
Hoboldt. Uh, Doctor Tilley is professor of politics in
the Department of Politics and International relations at the
University of Oxford and Dr. Hoboldt holds the Sutherland
Chair in the European Institutions and is also the
head of the department of government at the London
School of Economics and Political Science. And today we're
going to talk about their book Tribal Politics How
Brexit Divided Britain. So Dr. Tilley, Dr. Hoboldt, welcome
to the show. It's a huge pleasure to everyone.
Thanks very much for inviting me.
OK, so, uh, before we get into the sort
of political science that you explore in your book
related to Brexit and the political tribal tribalism that
derived from it, uh, tell us first. A little
bit about the history of Brexit. So what led
to it, uh, to it, I mean, in the
history of, uh, the politics of the United Kingdom,
what preceded Brexit?
I mean, I think the first thing to say
here is that Brexit was by no means inevitable.
Sometimes when we look back now that Brexit has
happened, we might think, oh, you know, all roads
would lead to this outcome. There was this sort
of major desire or public interest in having A
referendum on membership, but that was really far from
the case. In fact, when we, which we do
in the book, we trace public opinion on European
membership, the first thing to note is really that
people didn't care very much about the EU or
EU membership. So when David Cameron, uh, the Prime
Minister who called the referendum, when he first promised
the referendum back in 2013, only about 2% of
the British population even mentioned it as one of
the most salient issues. And in the, in the
election that came after that in 2015, it wasn't
really one of the debated issues at all. It
was not even in the top 10 of issues
that people cared most about. So it wasn't the
sort of public salience that led to the referendum.
But the issue of EU membership had been an
issue of conflict and debate in British politics for
a long time, but mainly amongst political elites. So
first, the Labour Party and then the Conservative Party
were really divided on the issue of EU membership,
and that was the primary reason why David Cameron
decided to hold the referendum, because he wanted to
quell or appease the. Divisions within his own party
and there was also new pressures from the Eurosceptic
UKIP party on the right and so he thought
by having that referendum he could sort of solve
that issue within his party in that way because
of course he expected to win the referendum. So
by winning that issue it would sort of put
a line on there and say now we've dealt
with Europe, so. So that's really what was so
interesting and what we deal with in our book
Tribal Policy is that EU membership went from an
issue that most people didn't care that much about.
It wasn't particularly salient to an issue that came
to be a political identity, something that really defined
how people looked at themselves and how they looked
at the world.
But historically, were there any precedents to Brexit in
Britain or or was it something unprecedented and if
it was unprecedented, in what ways was it unprecedented?
So it's not unprecedented in Britain or indeed elsewhere
in Europe. We've had, you know, over 50 referendums
on aspects of European integration and particularly there's a
very clear historical precedent in Britain which is 1975.
So in 1975 there was a similar referendum. So
Britain had joined the European Union, uh, together with
Ireland and Denmark in 1973, um, but the Labour
Party at the time had was split on it.
And so we had a Labour Prime Minister in
1975, Harold Wilson, who decided again. In a similar
parallel to what happened with David Cameron in 2016,
his own party was divided on the issue, so
perhaps the referendum would be seen as a good
way of solving that issue. So again, we have
these internal party tensions this time within the Labour
Party that led to a referendum on in-out membership
at that time of the European Economic Community. So
that's a very clear parallel. Now that's sort of
where the similarities stopped because of course what happened
in 1975 was a very big victory for staying
in the EEC. So about 2 to 1 of
people voted to stay in the EEC. So that
meant not that the issue in a sense went
away, particularly within the parties. It sort of rumbled
on, but it meant that because it was a
vote in favor of state. QUO. It didn't become
this sort of shock where there was continuous negotiations
about how the new arrangements should look like. Instead
it was like, OK, people have now voted quite
emphatically to stay in the EEC. We can now
continue that way. So it continued as an elite
sort of issue of conflict, but not as a
sort of big public salient issue.
So talking about the referendum itself, because I mean
I might be misremembering a little bit because back
in 2016 I didn't really follow it extremely closely,
but I remember that when the results came out,
people, many people. WERE sort of surprised that Brexit
had won, that leaving the European Union had won.
So, but were there any signs that that could
happen before it did, or and what was its
immediate fallout?
Um, I mean, I think actually the interesting thing
there is that. While perhaps there were some perceptions
that it was a done deal for Remain that
Remain would win, actually the polls were very, very
close for the whole 6 months beforehand. I mean,
you're talking about like maybe a 1% lead on
average, which was pretty much unchanging, um, over that
period. And I think that's really important for our
story because it meant there were two evenly sized
groups in the population basically pitted against each other.
And I think the other important thing for our
story is sort of the the opposite of what
happened in 1975. Um, THAT it was, uh, not
only close, but it was also a vote for
change. So 75, it's, it's a big majority for
staying in the EU and it's also the status
quo. 2016, very, very tight result and a vote
against the status quo. And so I think the
immediate fallout, which is actually really relevant, um, uh,
for, for what we're interested in, is that everyone
therefore had to decide what Brexit actually meant. And
how it was going to be enacted and all
of that was going to take some period of
time during which this would be a very, very
salient issue, unlike as Sara was saying beforehand when
basically no one really, um, cared about it. So
these two things are really crucial to our stories,
these evenly sized groups, a tight results, and a
big constitutional question that then needs to be decided
over a period of time, um, after the actual
referendum.
Mhm. But in the immediate aftermath, I mean, how
did the people across the country react to it,
across the United Kingdom? I mean, were people mostly
surprised? Were people sort of expecting that result, or
what?
Um, I think the. I would say there was
a degree of surprise because of the way in
which the, the polling had been interpreted to indicate
that because Remain had a lead most of the
time, that meant they were going to win. um,
AND so I think there was a degree of
surprise because of that, and I think there was
also a degree of surprise amongst elites, and that's
most elites. So if you think about what I
mean by that, let's say academics, journalists, um, most
politicians were on the side of Remain. And as
we're going to talk about, people like to project
what they think, uh, how the world is, uh,
how the world, uh, should be and pretend that
that's how the world is. And so I think
a lot of them were surprised because they didn't,
they themselves perhaps didn't meet many people who were
going to vote leave and so didn't, and, and
therefore didn't really quite believe that it was close.
Um, AND so I think surprise was more concentrated
amongst those people than perhaps it was among the
general public in some ways.
And famously, of course, apparently the, the, the leaders
of the leave camp themselves, including Boris Johnson, was
quite surprised and sort of slept through it. At
least that's the, uh, that's the sort of modern
political history of the event that he had to,
that he wasn't awake. And then he had to
go and give this speech because one of the
things that, and, and we write about in the
that that is quite telling that it wasn't only
this event, which I think you're right, was to
many people, particularly that the opinion formers was surprising,
but it was also the fact that there wasn't
really a clear plan, a roadmap. Had we voted
by the same margin, 52 to 48 to stay
in, it was pretty clear, you know, not much
would have happened. But all of a sudden there
was this result where There wasn't a clear roadmap,
not by the official leave campaign, you know, in
fact, many people had campaigned for slightly different things,
of course. Then you have a Prime Minister, David
Cameron resigning, and so you have to then have,
and so, so there were a lot of things
that were not settled, so it wasn't just the
immediate surprise, but also the fact all of a
sudden people We, oh my goodness, what do we
do now, including probably some quite central figures in
the on the leave side that there wasn't a
kind of a, they never had to have had
a clear agreement or roadmap for what that leave,
what Brexit would would look like and of course
we all know that Theresa May kept saying Brexit
means Brexit, and everyone was like, well, that's a
sort of slight tautology, and that was partly to
avoid this discussion of what that actually meant while
they were figuring it out within the party.
Right, so we're going to talk more about Brexit
and its consequences, but I would like to now
do it by exploring the central topics that you
talk about in your book. So since we're going
to talk about political tribalism here, what is actually
a tribal politics? I mean, what is tribalism in
the, in the political context?
I mean that's a, that is a good question.
It is obviously at the heart of the book.
The book's called Tribal Politics after all. Um, I
think, uh, there's a number of different aspects we
could talk about, but I, I think there's two
kind of key elements that we sort of focus
on in the book and I think probably we're
going to focus on in our discussion too. And
the first is about, uh, in-groups versus out-groups, us
versus them. So the idea that we create, um,
we adopt, we join a political group that we
consider to be ours, um, in some way. We
feel attached to people in that group, we feel
attached to the identity, attached to the label, um,
and part of that is also, therefore, uh, disliking
people in the out-group. Having prejudice against, against people
in the out-group and in favor of the in-group,
discriminating against the out-group, discriminating in favor of the,
uh, the in-group, um, and I think that's the
first, Element, um, of what we think of as
political tribalism. I think the second element is sort
of, uh, sometimes easy to overlook, but it's actually
perhaps in, in some ways more important, and that's
the way we kind of construct the world around
us based on those group identities or we construct
our perceptions of the world around us. So we
sort of see reality through the lens of the
political, um, identity. Adopt policy positions on the basis
of it. We might judge how well or badly
democracy is functioning through that lens, uh, and so
on. So it's these kind of two things. On
the first hand, uh, on the one hand, you've
got this kind of in-group out-group dynamics, and then
you've also, on the other hand, got this kind
of consequences of those in-group out-group dynamics in terms
of how it shapes, uh, the way we see
and interact with, in our case, the political world,
but also I guess more broadly the social world.
We might perhaps talk a bit about both of
those, um, later on.
Yeah, right, so the two political tribes that developed
after Brexit or during Brexit and then more so
after it, you call them in your book the
leavers and the Remainers. How did each of them
develop and what would you say characterizes them and
makes them opposites of one another?
So I think the first thing to say there
is that it's not just that we call them
leavers and remainers, it's that they call themselves levers
and remainers. And so these aren't, these aren't labels
we are attaching to groups. They're the labels the
groups themselves use to describe both their own group
and the other group. And that's actually a really
important part of what's, of, of, of what we're
interested in, um, so. The vast majority of people
who voted in the referendum subsequently identified themselves as
Leavers and Remainers, about 80% of people, um, immediately
after the referendum, and in fact, today, so 10
years after the referendum, 60% of people still are
willing to call themselves a Leaver or Remainer. They
still think of themselves in that way, um, which
is about the same amount of people, maybe even
slightly more, more than the number of people who
are willing to identify as a political party supporter.
So just to give you sort of context for
that. Um How did they develop? Well, I think,
um. I mean, they developed ultimately and sort of
Sarah touched on this right at the beginning because
of the people being forced to make a choice
at the referendum, so to vote for one side
or the other, you had to convert your position
on an issue, an issue which most people didn't
really have a very strong view on, but they
had maybe some vague view on, uh, EU integration,
and then convert that view into picking one side
or the other, and then you became part of
one group or the other. Um, IN fact, I
mean, the, the names Leavers and Remainers, I mean,
the, the, that, they, they're derived from the options
on the ballot paper. You could vote to leave
or vote to remain. So you could have had
a yes, no, you know, option, and then people
perhaps would have been yeses and, um, and, uh,
and noers or nayers, as they're sometimes called in
Scotland, where it was a yes, no kind of
outcome for the Scottish independence referendum. Um, SO I
think the really crucial thing to understand is that.
What characterizes these two groups is how they voted
in the referendum, yeah, it's the issue position, uh,
that they held, but then the choice that they
made in June 2016 for one option, um, or
the other. I mean, we, we might want to
talk a bit about the social characteristics of both
sides as well, perhaps if you want, but I
think the. The essence of having an issue-based identity,
which is what we think this is, is you
have a position at issue, you then are forced
to make a choice, a binary choice in this
case, and then that creates two groups, which are
going to be naturally, um, in opposition, uh, to
one another. Um, I think the only thing perhaps
to add to that is, is also worth just
saying, the nature of an issue position on any
political issue is lots of people are in the
middle. Um, AND that's true for the EU, uh,
issue as well. But those people, they went into
the referendum and they had to make a choice.
So they might, so two people might have had
quite similar views actually on EU integration, but when
they went and voted, one voted to leave and
one voted remain. And so subsequently, they became leavers
and remainers. So the the translation of the issue
position into the, um, identity means that you've got
a spectrum. That then becomes a sort of binary
set of categories, um, that's what we call two
categories. So it's, it's kind of a different, uh,
a different kind of idea. It's a, quite an
important element of how these issues become identities effectively.
I think.
Yeah, but this sort of tribalistic dynamics that can
develop in the political realm, let's say. I mean,
can something like this happen around any sort of
potential uh topic or issue, or is it that,
er, when it comes to Brexit, it had certain
types of characteristics that made it, er, that people
who fell on either the leaver or remainer camp.
Uh, BECAME that for, uh, that tribalistic.
I mean, I think, I think the starting point
in terms of how we look at it is
that it isn't really about the nature of the
issue or even how strongly people feel about the
issue to start off with, because as we talked
about, in fact, people didn't feel particularly strongly about
the EU or it wasn't something that affected their
lives very much. Of course you're always going to
get a hardcore people who are Europhiles or really
Eurosceptics, but they were a tiny minority in Britain.
Um, IN fact, most people were sort of maybe
broadly we call kind of indifferent Eurosceptics, uh, in
the book. So they were sort of a bit
skeptical, uh, uh, of the whole European thing, but
that didn't necessarily mean that they had to, um,
You know, you know, they would vote to leave.
I mean, exactly what happened with the referendum is
it created these two, it compelled people to be
in one or two camps. So the starting point
is people have, there are lots of political issues.
Most of them don't become identities, but some do,
and that's really part of a social and political
process, and, and, and what. Brexit was this sort
of Goldilocks combination of factors that created the conditions
where an issue like Europe did become something that
became really at the heart of it became a
tribal issue with two camps, so it's not just
about, oh, it couldn't happen to other issues, but
it's also not, oh it happens to most political
issues,
right, I understand. And how is the discussion surrounding
Brexit Brexit evolved over these past 10 years? I
mean, are people really still that entrenched when it
comes to their tribalism surrounding this topic, if of
course they fall on the camp of the leavers
or the Remainers and not in the middle, or
are people. More, uh, tribalized or more polarized when
it comes to that issue nowadays than they were
10 years ago in the immediate aftermath of the
referendum or how have things evolved basically?
I think uh we can sort of look at
two things here. One is the issue about how
the identities have evolved, and another is sort of
what are are general attitudes also amongst those who
don't hold identities on Brexit. And when it comes
to the identities, I think what's really quite extraordinary
is how sticky they've been. We're now more than
a decade on from the referendum. If you read
British newspapers or watch British television or listen to,
you know, even our new Prime Minister, you won't
hear Andy Burnham talk a lot about Brexit. Uh,
IN fact, uh, the Labour Party, I think, quite
deliberately avoids talking a lot about it. So it's
not really as a sort of headline news the
way it was for, you know, 56 years, constantly
bombarded with news about Brexit. Everything was about Brexit.
So if you just look at the news coverage,
you would think, oh, Brexit is over, it's done.
But if you look at, uh, and we've traced
really across a decade public opinion and identities, you
see that because it's more than your opinion. It
is these identities about how we see ourselves, they
have that stickiness to it. So as James mentioned,
we still have over 60% of people still identifying
as either leave or remainer. Even the term remainer
doesn't really make sense anymore because we've, of course,
left the EU, but it's still something people use
to describe themselves. So that's quite extraordinary in that
way and also really shows that how it's more
than just an issue of opinion. Now that's even
higher amongst those people who voted back in 2016.
Now, so if we look on the other hand,
at attitudes towards Brexit, it might look like there's
been a shift, and so how do we reconcile
that? So if we look at now, we ask
people, do you think it was a good thing
or a bad thing for the United Kingdom to
leave the European Union, there's now quite a big
majority that would say that it's a bad thing,
yeah. Uh, SORT of, um, in the region of
kind of, uh, uh, 55, 60% who consistently, it
would say it's a bad thing. Um, NOW, that
has to do with not so much that lots
of people who identify strongly as leaders have changed
their minds. That's not really what's going on. Of
course, there will be some people who've changed their
minds, but a couple of things are going on.
One is just demographic change. So if you look
at how The population in Britain has evolved for
the last decade. Older people were more likely to
be leavers than younger people, and they're the ones
who have sadly, some of them left the electorate,
while the younger people who can now vote are
more likely to say, to be more positive about
the EU. And another thing is for those people
who didn't vote back in 2016 or who didn't
develop an identity, they're more likely to say, oh,
this sounds like this Brexit thing was a bad
thing. So we have seen a kind of shift.
Even if we ask about the question of rejoin,
uh, it's now about 55% who would rejoin. Uh,
THAT you, uh, if, if you ask it in
that way, um, uh, so, so there has been
a sort of more EU positive or Brexit negative
shift, but the, the main thing in terms of,
uh, the identities is that they're still there in
quite high numbers, uh, despite the sort of the
lower salience of the issue.
And I think one thing to add to that
is that there's, there's very few people sort of
hint that there's very few people switching between the
identities. They've become quite fixed with those people. Maybe
some people have left the identity, they've gone to
not having one at all, but they've not switched
sides. And so most of the, most of the
kind of change in sort of those headline numbers
that, um, Sarah mentioned about support for say, rejoining,
that's actually coming from people who didn't develop an
identity, um, in, in 2016 or in the immediate
aftermath.
Right, uh, yes, I, I'm going to ask you
more about issue-based identities in a second, but just
before that, when it comes to social identities, is
it that people identifying as leavers or remainers track
onto any sort of demographics, like, for example, I
remember that. Right after Brexit, there were people trying
to make sense of what might have caused people
to vote one way or the other, and they
were talking, for example, that it was really about
the young versus the older people with high educational
attainment versus low educational attainment and They also, certain
people also tried to make it about uh class
divisions. I mean that people who were low socioeconomic
status were more likely to be leavers and uh
high socioeconomic status, more like. TO be remainder, things
like that. I mean, is any of that true?
And if so, do any of those sort of
social categories track onto this division or not?
Um, I think that's that's yes and no. Um,
SO I'll start with the yes and then I'll
go on the no perhaps. Um, I think the,
the yes is that like with most political attitudes,
there are social characteristics, exactly the ones you mentioned
in this case, um, age, education, to some extent,
social class. In our case, actually national identity, um,
would be the one that do predict people's views
about the European, um, Union. Education is probably the
best of those things that you mentioned in terms
of the predictor. And they also predicted, therefore, how
people voted in the, um, referendum. Um, THAT'S the
yes bit. I think the no bit though is
that. They're not very good predictors of people's attitudes
and people's vote, and I think that that's quite
surprising, I think, to some people because exactly like
you just said, the referendum is sometimes presented as
a, you know, a class conflict or an age
conflict or or whatever it is, um, but I
think some of that's really about people. You know,
humans like to be able to sort of describe
the person on either side in this case, and
so we sort of reach for these things that
might be, you know, relatively slightly correlated with the,
with these issue opinions, and then we describe or
think of people in those, in those ways, but
Actually, if we model people's vote choice at the
referendum, you know, using these kind of social characteristics
and, you know, at least the models we use,
we've got a very long list, they're very well
measured, um, and some really good measures of national
identity, but we don't actually do a very good
job of predicting, um, how someone voted. And there's,
there's sort of 22 reasons for that. One is
that the, simply the relationship between those characteristics and
people's vote is just not that strong, um. But
the second bit, which is perhaps a bit more
subtle, is that where there is strength, the strength
is at the extremes. So by that, what I
mean is, let's say we took education. So people
with very high levels of education, um, so people
with a PhD, say, um. They tend to be,
uh, much more supportive of EU membership than the
average person, but there's not very many people with
a PhD out there. So you could sort of
say, well, education is a good predictor, but it's
only a good predictor for a small segment of
the population at the extremes, and then the same
is true for, say, national identity. So people who
thought of themselves as Europeans, having a European nationality
were much more likely to be supportive of EU
membership, but prior to the referendum, um, we might
get onto it perhaps later on after the referendum
because it's changed a bit, prior to the referendum,
very few people thought of themselves as European, yeah,
something about 10, 15% of the population. So the
kind of characteristics we have don't really do a
very good job of, um, uh, of actually explaining
how people, uh, how people voted. So the amount
of variation we can explain in people's opinions is
actually not, um, not terribly high. So, you know,
it's not that leavers are just a, a, another
name for the working class and Remainers are just
another name, um, for the middle class. They're kind
of new political identities. Um, RATHER than just, um,
sort of old ones, uh, with a different label,
uh, attached to them.
So I would like to hear more from you
about issue-based identity. So what causes issue-based identities? I
mean what leads to the development or what are
the factors that Help to convert an issue into
an identity and in the book you explore things
like issue contestation, issue expression, and issue alignment. So
could you tell us about that?
Perhaps, uh, a good place to start is what
is what a social identity is because what we're
interested here is really issue-based identity as a type
of social identity, and that's really what makes it
different from having an opinion on a political issue.
So, you know, social identity is a sense of
who we are as people based on what group
we belong to. And we have lots of these
social identities. So, you know, I might have a
social identity as a, you know, an academic and
a political scientist and a Londoner and a Danish
person, and they sort of form my perception of
who I am, but also who I'm not, like
who are the people who are not like that.
So, Both gives me a kind of a sense
of, of worth and self-esteem, uh, in terms of
basis of I, I belong to these groups, but
it can also sometimes, if these identities are polarized,
it can also then be a source of, you
know, outgroup prejudice and discrimination against the people who
are not like that. Like sometimes, uh, uh, I
think about it, uh, you know, yesterday I went
to a football match. I always think this is
like the pinnacle of where you can really see,
you know, these social identities and outgroup things in
action, because here you have, you know, I just
happen to have Fulham ticket, you know, Fulham season
tickets, which is sort of a bit random in
a way. But once you're sitting there in the
stands, you're like, we're the best, and these other
guys are complete losers and sort of worse words.
So that's the sort of the in-group feeling. Uh,
AND also the outgroup animus in, in play. Now,
so, so that's a social identity and often, uh,
the literature and political science have focused a lot
on social identities that were based on more, we
might think of as scriptive characteristics like, oh, it
might be race, or it might be Gender, it
might be class or, or, or partisanship, which is
the perhaps the most powerful social political based social
identity that we often think of that predicts all
sorts of things like attitudes and voting behavior and
so on. And so the, to, to answer your
question, to get to issue-based identity, that's really where
you have a political issue that where you form
an that you have a view on, and you
form an identity on the basis of other people
holding the same view on that issue. Uh, AND,
and, and some people holding the opposite view or
a different view. Now, of course, we have lots
of views on, on things in, in politics and
policy that never, you know, lead to an identity.
I might like low taxes or I might like
regular bin collection, but I don't go around thinking,
oh, I'm the sort of once a week bin
collector person or the low tax, even the low
tax person. I mean, some people might have an
identity based on that, but most don't. It's just
views you have, yeah. So, so really what we,
you know, that's why it's the sort of the
puzzle, one of the puzzles of the book is,
so when does, as we show quite clearly, an
issue become um uh something that's the basis of
an identity and also the basis of tribal politics.
And, and as I mentioned before, that's really a
part of not just really the issue itself, but
the how that issue plays out politically and socially.
And that's why we have these, these 3, kind
of, you know, conditions to sort of think about
how could that work beyond Brexit, the sort of
issue contestation, uh, issue expression, and also lack of
issue alignment. Uh, HAPPY to, to sort of elaborate
on that, but that's, that's really, that's really where
we get from the social identity, the issue identity.
Yes, please elaborate a little bit more on that,
particularly on the factor related to issue alignment.
Yes, so, so, um, so the three factors are
really ones where we all see them in Brexit,
but we also think that they could characterize why
other issues become identities. So starting with. CONTESTATION, not
surprisingly for an issue to become an identity, something
people feel strongly and emotively about. It has to
be something that's heavily contested, sort of very salient,
not only salient, but also where there's considerable disagreement
between, you know, political actors, between people in the
population. So in Brexit, of course, we went from
a point where this was not a heavily contested
issue, but by calling a referendum, all of a
sudden, it became everything everyone talked about, and that
didn't stop with the referendum. We then had 56
years where it was all everyone talked about, because
it was then the question of what Brexit, what
does it look like? And a constant refighting of
this issue. Should we really remain in the EU?
Would there be a no-deal Brexit, and so on.
So it was constantly contested. Now, the second thing
is what we call issue expression, because sometimes issues
can be contested at the elite level, but we
as citizens never really have to commit. And that's
with a lot of issues like the taxation issue.
Oh, we might have views, but we're not really
committing. We might be in the sort of middle,
oh, I like low taxes, but I also like
a big welfare state, but I'm never really asked
to commit, am I in the low tax, small
state, or in the high tax, high state category.
I just sort of can have my cake and
eat it. Now what happened when there's issue expression
is you have to commit in some way, uh,
uh, on one side or the other. Now, of
course, what we do in an election or in
a referendum, here you had all these people, many
of whom were in the middle, they committed, they
were compelled to either vote. Physically go down, put
a cross. Now, once I've put that cross, I
can no longer be this, you know, ambivalent person
in the middle, because I have committed to saying
no, in fact, I am a leaver, and I
then have to sort of keep thinking about, well,
I'd like to, I don't like to be wrong.
So once I've said, OK, leave is the way
it goes, then when news comes out, oh, maybe
Brexit wasn't good, I'm like, Oh, that's not great,
because I can't be wrong, because I took the
right choice. I committed to that choice. So I
will see things through that lens. Similarly, if I
vote to remain, I'm going to interpret everything like,
God, Brexit was terrible, and I was right all
along. So that's the sort of issue expression. Now,
that's not just a vote, we can, you know,
some people, I'm sure you know, people like that,
they go on social media. And they express, they
recommit to their issue, you know, to their view
on a particular issue, or in the case of
Brexit, we had the biggest online petition ever of
people who said they wanted a second referendum or
people's vote on the EU. So that's a way
that we keep recommitting to conversation with peers online,
offline, and so on. So that the expression then
rarefies, calcifies our identities in a way that simply
having a view doesn't do. And the final thing
is this lack of issue alignment. So here, that
might seem a bit counterintuitive, but we're arguing if
an issue, a conflict over an issue is not
neatly aligned with existing partisan or party competition, it's
more likely to become a new identity. So some
issues like the ones I discussed about tax, they
form perhaps quite neatly into Labour versus Conservative. So
if I decide I'm a super low tax person,
it's pretty obvious that I should probably commit myself
to the Conservatives over Labour. Some people might dispute
that, but let's just see sort of broadly that
that's how it would be. So it falls on
a kind of existing conflict dimension that we know.
So there's no need to invent a new political
identity. In contrast, if you have an issue where
the parties are split, then And it doesn't neatly
align. First of all, you don't get sort of
clear cues from the parties about how to, but
also then if this is now the issue that
I feel more strongly about than anything else, then
a new identity can emerge. And Brexit again was
an example of that. Especially the Conservative Party, was
clearly split. You had David Cameron advocating the key
person of the Remain side advocating to vote to
stay in the EU, so a Remainer, and you
had the key person of the Leave side, Boris
Johnson, also a very prominent Conservative. Uh, PARTY politicians
advocating to leave the EU. So already here, uh,
the parties were split, and there was also Labour
politicians. So that lack of alignment with the sort
of main dominant partisan conflict means that if a
new issue becomes salient, it's more likely to form
a new identity, and we can, we can think
of parallels with things like independence votes in Scotland.
In Catalonia and so on. Again, where the parties
are not, where partisan supporters are split internally and
then you get these, these new identities emerging.
Right. Yeah, uh, uh, let me just say really
quickly that you touched very briefly on football there,
and I really want to avoid that topic altogether
because I, I, I want to try to maintain
my my. Impartiality here, but, but objectively here in
Portugal, Porto is superior to Benfica, but
that's the fact. I'll I'll say that's fine. That's
fine, yeah.
OK, so, but, so these identities, uh, around issues
develop, uh, socially, politically. What are then the kinds
of political and social consequences that, uh, the development
of these identities can have? I mean, what, in
what ways can those uh uh the uh or
this kind of phenomenon change society and politics?
I mean, I think it goes back to almost
when we were defining what tribal politics is, to
be honest, because At the sort of social level
you've got this us versus them dynamic between these,
these two kind of, you know, relatively arbitrary defined
groups. People think people in their own group are
better than people in the other group, they want
to spend more time with people in their own
group than people um in the other group, they
discriminate in favor of their own group versus the
other group, um, and so on. So I think
that I actually is quite an important social consequence
because it means it's a, it's a way of
sort of, uh. Um, HOW you interact with other
people is changed because of it. You, you are
choosing to interact in different ways with people on
the basis of those, um, identities. The second consequence
you also mentioned was this way in which Be
Sara sort of touched on there, um, when she
was talking about her, uh, her, uh. Attendance at
Fulham, which is you view the world in a
different way, yeah, you, you sort of, uh, you
see whatever, whether the referee is good or bad
at the football match, but in the context of
our thing, whether the economic performance of the country
is good, where, whether democracy is working well, what
policy positions are, are, are correct through that lens
of the identity. And I think there is then
a final consequence, which is, um, uh, so it
goes back to what Sara was saying about the,
um, the sort of idea of issue alignment. Because
It may well be the case that prior to
these new identities, uh, being created, that they're not
aligned, say, with the, uh, with People's Party identities.
But a possible consequence of this is that parties
have to react to the new identities and so
organize themselves in, in, in different kinds of ways
around those new, um, identity, uh, groupings. So parties
might shift to try and, you know, accommodate them
to win over perhaps voters organized on those, around
those divisions. So I think that's a sort of
a, a more directly, in this case, party political
consequence, but. To be honest, I actually see the
consequences as perhaps more importantly, at the kind of
social level, um, how just how individuals go about
their daily lives and, and, and perceive the world.
Uh, YES, and related to that in the book
you explore phenomena like in-group affect, out-group animosity and
prejudice, and effective polarization. So, um, what do those
kind of phenomena allow for us to understand about
the social dynamics that surround, um. That that surround
basically these issue-based identities that develop and in the
case of Brexit, the leavers and the remainder.
Um, I mean, I think on, on, on, on,
on specifically those, those kind of elements, um, the
phenomenon is actually, I guess, relatively straightforward, which is
we start with in-group affect. That's basically means people
like people like them, yeah, and they're defining like
them in terms of this new identity. And so
we, we know that people are generally like people
like them, but the interesting question is how they
define what is like them. Is it that, um,
You know, Sarah mentioned her various identities. Is it
that we're both, um, professors, we were both academics,
or is it that she's a London and I'm
not, you know, if depending on which of those
you pick, we are part of the same identity
or we're opposed to one another, um, well, opposed
is perhaps a bit strong, but anyway, uh, let's
not get into that. But, um, but, you know,
so. But here what we're saying is these Brexit
identities became how people define themselves and so it's
that, you know, one of the key ways in
which people might talk about themselves, think about themselves.
Um, AND I mean, I won't go into great
detail, but you know, we, we try and measure
this in lots of different ways in the book.
A, a really common way is, um, to use,
uh, what are called feeling thermometers where you, you
ask people how favorable or unfavorable they are to
people on, uh, different groups, running from 0 to
100, 100 is you, you know, absolutely love them
and 0 is you absolutely hate them. Um, IF
we ask people about people on their own side
of the Brexit identity group, they're giving scores of
about 80, which is pretty high in this context.
You know, for example, the, um, scores for, say,
Labour and Conservative and Liberal Democrat identifiers, so party
identifiers are more like 60 or 70. So this
has got much stronger, people got much stronger in-group
feeling towards, um, people on their Brexit, uh, side
of the, uh, divide than they have actually for
the, for the party political, um, things. Other measures
would be, um, I think we have a sort
of battery of items, but, uh, that try and
get emotional attachment. So, and I, I, I always
think that one of the best items there is,
um, When you ask people, when you speak about
people on your own side, do you say we
or they? And I always think that gets to
the heart of the matter, that you're actually describing
people in this group as a we, you're part
of them. Um, AND we see really quite high
levels of agreement with those kind of statements for
these, uh, for both Remainers and leavers, and again,
higher than they are for party identities, um, in
the main, which is the, you know, the, a
convenient comparison point for us in a way because
it, it's sort of saying, well, look. What is
the primary in-group identification, uh, the primary political identity
in-group identification in Britain? Actually, for the last 10
years, in the main, it's been not parties, it's
been actually these Brexit groups, which I think is,
is quite striking, uh, in some ways. Certainly as
political scientists, I think. You know, when we talk
about political identity, we almost just say, we always
just mean party identity. They're almost synonymous to some
extent, um, and yet here we actually see something
quite different. Um, AND then on, in terms of
the other things you mentioned, so the outgroup animosity
and prejudice, I mean, in a way, it's just
sort of flip it over and we see the
the the same kind of thing. So again, take
those feeling thermometers. Um, SO 0 to 100. What
do you think about the other side? Well, people
are giving scores they're about 20 or 30, so
really quite low. Um, PEOPLE really quite dislike the
other side. They're saying they have a cold, unfavorable
feeling about, about the other side. Um, BUT I
think again, like perhaps more striking than that is
to look at, um, perhaps prejudice and things like
discrimination, uh, so. We find really, I, I would
say quite high levels of prejudice in favor of
the in-group over the out-group, and there's lots of
different ways to measure that, but, um, a really
classic way is basically to ask people about positive
and negative adjectives about, uh, different groups. Um, AND
what you find is that people say, oh, my
own side, uh, who, whichever one they are, yeah,
they're honest, they're intelligent, they're selfless, and so on
and so forth. So loads of good traits, um.
The other side, oh no, they're dishonest, they're selfish,
they're hypocritical, and a load of, of bad traits,
and these are quite big differences in the way
that people would describe the two groups. They'll ascribe
traits, bad traits to the other side and good
traits to their own side. Their own, you know,
your own side, paragon's a virtue. The other side,
awful people, um. And I mean, yeah, I could
go on. Oh, perhaps there's one other thing I'll
mention, which is about, um, we also asked people
to describe in their own words what the other
side was like, uh, and indeed their own side.
Um, SO it's an open-ended question, you can write
whatever you want. And I think what's really fascinating
there is that, of course, some people describe the
other side in terms of, um, some of the
social characteristics you mentioned earlier, but often also the
issue itself. So these are people who voted this
way or have these views. But a lot of
people. Uh, ESSENTIALLY just insults the other side. So
25% of people, all they do is give insults
about the other side. Um, SO, you know, to
give you a couple of examples, uh, brainwashed morons,
selfish dicks, etc. ETC. YEAH. These are not very
complimentary terms. Um, I, I could go on. In
fact, these are, these are, these are the more,
um, uh, some of the other options are probably
not, not, uh, not ideal for the podcast, yeah,
so like people are quite rude, um, so not
everyone's willing to do that, but a, a substantial
minority of people are, and I think. It does
reveal something that that kind of level of prejudice
about, um, maybe not exactly how people are dehumanizing
the other side, but regarding them as lesser people,
inferior people, uh, in one way or another, and
I, I think that is quite an important social,
um, uh, kind of consequence, um, of these new
identities because. It's not that people weren't doing that
before, of course, but they were using different criteria
for which people, for which group they were in
and which people or groups other people were in.
And this is, uh, this has now become, uh,
more about these political, um, identity groups, uh, based
on the referendum vote.
And er can this lead to discrimination and if
so, how does discrimination manifest in this particular context?
I mean, maybe just, maybe just briefly, I mean,
I think James described it very well that it
really flows for this from this idea that part
of what in-group and out-group, uh, polarization is about
is that you consider your own. Group as superior
to the other side. And of course, if you
do indeed see the other side as, as inferior,
it also makes sense that in a lot of
contexts, you would want to choose, uh, your own
side, someone belonging to your group over the other,
you know, that almost sort of, uh, you know,
if you do indeed think they have to think
that people on the other side have all these
character flaws, then why would you not, uh, you
know, in a sense be biased or prejudiced against
them when choosing. And just the one little example
of that is we ran this experiment where instead
of asking people specifically about leavers and remainers and
their characteristics, we gave people sort of examples of
CVs for who they might choose to rent a
room to, you know, to be a lodger in
their home. And so, you know, and they would
have lots of things like what job do they
have, uh, you know, what, what did they vote?
The last general election, you know, what kind of
age, education, you know, the kind of things. And
you might think, oh, you want someone who has
a well paying job and is a good cook
or something like that. That's what you would think.
But in fact, what really came out most strongly
was that people did not want to live with
someone who was, if they were a Remainer, a
leaver, or vice versa. In other words, they discriminated
a lot on the basis of uh Brexit identities.
Now, that might be because they don't want to
discuss Brexit, but it might also be because exactly
like James said, they associated someone being, let's say
a remainer with lots of other negative traits, uh,
and therefore that in a sense that identity became
part of who that person was. So, so that's
an, that's an example exactly of how those identities
also therefore can lead to discrimination in scenarios where
that really wouldn't be about politics at all.
And this kind of uh identity formation, let's say,
and the the social dynamics that develop around it.
Uh, CAN also have, uh, a cognitive impact, uh,
on people, right? Because in the book you talk
about phenomena like confirmation bias and rationalization. So, uh,
could you tell us a little bit about that
in what ways, uh, people's cognition might operate in
a way that goes according to the interests of
the group they are now part of.
Yeah, I mean, uh, it'd be easy to tell
you a lot about it, but I'll try and
tell you a little about it, um, because there's,
there's a lot there, I guess, actually. Um, BUT
it, but in essence, like these strongly, these strongly
held group identities, you know, they bias people in
various ways, effectively towards ways in which it flatters
their own side and sort of discredits the other
side. Um, I think it's worth saying actually perhaps
just a bit about why that might happen, like
what the mechanism is there. Um, ONE possibility is
obviously people want consistency in their views and opinions,
you know, it's psychologically disconcerting to not have that
kind of consistency. The other possibility is it's kind
of more of a signaling mechanism, so you want
to hold particular beliefs and opinions to signal something
to typically people on your own side that you're
a good person, you have the right views and
things like that. So, um. One thing I always
want to sort of emphasize this, this isn't, people
aren't being irrational here necessarily, yeah, um, because it
makes sense to try and curry favor with people,
um, by adopting the, the kind of the right
views for your group and to make truth kind
of secondary to those considerations. So it's not, it's
not that this is sort of irrational, um. Tribalism
doesn't necessarily mean irrationality. It just means sort of,
uh, um, adopting behaviors that are going to, uh,
um, promote, promote you within the, within the, within
the group. Um, ANYWAY, that, that's perhaps by the
by, but I mean, I think it is useful
just to quickly talk about that a little bit,
um. And it's definitely the case people do engage
in motivated reasoning. There's a lot of examples. Uh,
WE could give, um, I, I think perhaps one
of the, I'll just give one because I guess
time's marching on, but I think 11 example that
I think, um, is in some ways perhaps the
most striking is the, uh, the way in which
people regard, um, sort of democratic functioning. So one
of the things we talk about in the book
is the, the way in which people, uh, whether
people think the referendum was fair or not, whether
it was a sort of a fair democratic process.
And I think one of the really interesting things
there is if you look before the referendum had
happened when, um, as we talked about, the broadly
speaking, people thought Remain were going to win. Remainers
said that it was going to be very fair
and leavers said it was going to be very
unfair. As soon as the referendum happened and Leave
won, Remainers immediately said it had been unfair and
Leavers said, oh no, it was very fair. So
people adopted their view, changed their views of the,
uh, sort of fairness of the democratic process, and
these are big changes, not small changes, um, depending
on whether they, whether they'd won, um, uh, or
lost, and. You know, what, even today, about 60%
of remain, over 60% of Remains I think still
say that the referendum was not based on a
fair democratic process. That's a lot, a lot of
people who are questioning, um, a kind of, you
know, basic, uh, basic part of, uh, democratic, um,
functioning, and, and the reason for that is, is
to go back to those mechanisms is because you
can, you know, you can, uh. You can feel
that you won, that you, you, you're superior in
some way because that's your side really won. You
can signal to fellow, in this case, Remainers, you're
a good group member, you have the right opinion,
uh, and you can cast down the virtue of
the side because they cheated. They were, they were,
they were unfair in some ways. So it's very
appealing to kind of believe these kind of things,
to adapt your views to, uh, basically better match
your better match your group, um, identity. Um, I
don't think there's anything you want to add to
that, Sarah. I mean,
just, I mean, another example that I think also.
Really is relevant to what we discussed before when
we said is how have, how has the sort
of debate on Brexit developed is when you look
at views on the economy, economy. So what I
get quite a lot when I'm presenting this work
is people, people say, well, you know, uh, I
don't understand why anyone can still be supporting Brexit
because it's been terrible for the economy. And often
on the basis of that question, you can sort
of maybe guess which side of the identity divide.
BECAUSE if you look at views on the economy,
uh, just generally, not even just views on how
the effect of Brexit on the economy, for the
EU economy, that's really divided along Brexit lines. What's
fascinating is we actually looked at how people who
ended up voting leave and remain, what were their
views on how well the economy was doing in
the run up to the referendum, and they weren't
actually different. It's not that leavers were optimists and
remainers were pessimists. They were quite similar. Now what
happened almost overnight with the referendum is Remainers just
became incredibly pessimistic about the econ the British economy
and have, have remained so and leavers have remained
sort of relatively more optimistic. So one thing is
you just see this divide, which we also know
in terms of partisan, the partisan lens that people
who are, let's say I'm a Trump supporter in
the US, I'm likely to think, oh, everything is
going amazingly well in the American economy. We're winning
all of these amazing trade wars and so on.
If I'm a Democrat, I'm likely to think everything
is just terrible. Yeah. And of course, the answer
is probably in some ways, the American economy is
doing well, and in some ways, it's perhaps not
doing as well, sort of, you know, but that's
not the partisan way of looking at it. And
that lens is also one we see that Brexit
identity is being used for this Brexit lens. And
sometimes it might be that both sides are a
bit, let's say pessimistic, for example, when there was
a spike in energy crisis, you might say, oh,
you know, everyone thinks that's not great. They recognize
that there's been a negative, uh, shock to the
economy. But how do you then attribute blame? If
you're a remainer, you're going to say, well, that's
clearly because of Brexit. If you're a leaver, you're
going to say, well, you know, there was Russia
invading Ukraine and all sorts of other things. So
we really see also when it comes to how
you interpret the world, that that is still today,
10 years on, shaped by your Brexit identities.
Right, so, uh, I would like to ask you
now, uh, this is something that usually falls more
on the camp of uh psychology because psychologists tend
to be more interested than political scientists in exploring
er people's individual traits. Instead of more, let's say,
social factors or factors that play out on a
collective level, but are individual psychological traits something that
you think might also play a role here when
it comes to people becoming more politically? Tribal, I,
I mean, are certain people with certain psychological traits
more likely to become tribal, or is that something
that you think perhaps it doesn't play that big
a role, at least compared to the other, um,
social factors we've already talked about?
Yeah, I mean, I think one of, one of
the questions we're interested in answering in the book
is kind of like, well, Well, basically why are
some people more attracted to their in-group identity and
why are some people more hostile than others and,
you know, one obvious explanation of course is some
people had stronger views on the original issue because
we were talking about an issue-based identity and obviously
that is part of the story, um, but another
part of the story is, is at least to
some extent the kind of, uh, personality traits or
the disposition or traits that people, people hold and
um. I mean, in terms of specifics, um, if
we look at the big five traits, then, uh,
neuroticism, uh, tends, tends to be, uh, correlated with
people who are more attached to their in-group, um,
actually both for the Brexit identity and party identity.
Uh, SO perhaps if you're high in neuroticism, you're
someone who derives a bit more comfort from knowing
you're a good member, um, of the in-group, and
so we certainly find a bit of that as
sort of psychological shield against threats which you feel
more strongly. Um, AND then the hostility to the
out-group, um, is people who are low in agreeableness,
um, which is not that surprising because disagreeable people
are generally kind of hostile to others, um, but
they're also, uh, hostile to others in the political
arena in terms of these political identity groups. So
that's the big five traits, but actually the, the
trait we find is kind of the most important,
um, is actually, uh, one of the dark triads,
so narcissism. Um, SO people in high in narcissism,
they think their in-group is, uh, superior to the
out-group, and they also are more hostile, um, sorry,
yeah, they're also more hostile to the out-group, and
that makes a lot of sense. Yeah, if you're
high in narcissism, you think you are superior to
other people, so it makes sense, you will think
your group is superior, um, to others, and you
tend to be a more antagonistic person, um, you
know, you're more rivalrous, uh, with others, and so
therefore more rivalrous between your group, uh, and other
groups, um. Uh, AND one of the sort of
interesting consequences of, of that is that, um, which
I, I, I, I find interesting anyway, perhaps because
I'm sort of very middle of the road and
lots of things, but it means that the people
who are quite extreme actually have something in common.
They're quite similar in some ways. They have these
kind of similar traits. Um, SO whether you're a
really, uh, attached leaver or really, really, uh, attached
remainer. You are likely to have on average, at
least, you know, more similar psychological traits to one
another than you are to, um, a fellow Remainer
or a Leaver who's, um, uh, who's, uh, who's
who's less attached to that identity. Um, SO yeah,
there's something to that. I, I wouldn't want to
overemphasize it, you know, these, these correlations are not
hugely strong, but they are definitely there and we
do consistently find them for both sides, you know,
and so it's not that narcissism predicts you're on
one side rather than the other, it predicts the
strength of your identity and your hostility to the
out-group for both groups.
Oh my God, don't tell me that, uh, horseshoe
theory is correct on a psychological level.
Not quite, but
yeah. OK, so, uh, toward the end of your
book, you talk about 4 different scenarios for the
continuing role of Brexit identities and you explore restoration,
revival, realignment, and replacement. Uh, SO what does each
of those possible scenarios correspond to, and, uh, I
mean, what do you think that one of them
is more likely than the others, or what can
we tell about that?
So in the book, because we were sort of
sitting a bit on the fence, uh, but now,
of course, uh, you know, things have happened, so
perhaps we can Uh, you know, also evaluate a
bit in terms of the evidence so far and
think about what has in fact occurred for the
sort of the four scenarios that we set out.
So one was restoration, and that was one thing,
oh, things will return to normal when it comes
to party competition in the UK, which means mainly
based on kind of classic economic issues, mainly with
the dominance of the Conservative and Labour Party, and
we're going to forget about this little episode in
British history where everything was about Brexit. And I
think that it's fair to say that that isn't
really what we're seeing. Uh, FIRST of all, the
issues that are kind of correlated with Brexit identities
to some extent, the kind of what we might
think of as cultural politics, the kind of more
identity-based issues, they are still very much dominating the
political debate, although of course the economy also matters.
But the other thing is also that the dominance
that we've seen in post-war of really 100 years
of British politics. OF these two major parties really
evaporated. So we have, if we look at the
polls, certainly, uh, Labour and Conservative both look a
lot weaker than they did going into this referendum
a decade ago. So we haven't certainly not seen
a full restoration act. It looks like Brexit has
sort of messed, shaken things up in some ways.
So then the question is, in what way, and
there I don't think we can fully give you
the answer, but we can speculate in what way
has this shakeup happened. So one is a realignment.
So that's saying, OK, uh, maybe, uh, uh, and
we see that, of course, in a lot of
Europe, not just um uh in Britain, that we've
seen this. It's not only about sort of left-right
economics. We have this second dimension that's really about
kind of cultural issues where issues like immigration. Uh,
NATIONAL sovereignty, uh, these sort of more identity-based cultural
issues matter a lot more, and they are really
the ones that decide voting behavior and party competition.
And Brexit kind of put that to the fore
with the issue of, of, of leaving or staying
in the European Union, but also a lot of
what was debated in the Brexit referendum was about
controlling borders, Do we want Britain to look like,
kind of these cultural issues. Um, AND that is
indeed what we're seeing. Also, we have seen, you
know, in the last few years, the emergence of
two, you know, particularly on the radical right, the
Reform UK led by Nigel Farage, which is a
strong kind of force that was really the key
topics are around cultural issues, mainly immigration. Um, BUT
also on the populist left, uh, with the Green
Party and its new leader that's really campaigning, uh,
uh, on the other side of that. So that's
the kind of realignment that Brexit in some ways,
um, uh, we think have given rise to. And
one of the reasons that even though Brexit isn't
ever on the ballot paper or really a key
issue is that when you look at patterns of
voting behavior, you can really see. Kind of Brexit
blocs. So you have the people who are leavers,
they vote for the Conservative and Reform UK overwhelmingly
in the sort of 80% plus, and the people
who are remainers vote overwhelmingly for what we might
think of the socially progressive parties, uh, Labour, Lib
Dems, and the Greens. So even though it isn't
about Brexit, we have seen this kind of realignment
around blocs. Then, um, the question of sort of
slightly more radical scenario is one of a replacement.
So that's to say perhaps Brexit, because it was
such a major political shock that gave rise to
new identities, will simply wipe out, uh, this, uh,
you know, uh, century-old dominance of Labour conservatives. They
were split on the issue. They couldn't contain it
within themselves. They gave, there were new political. Identities
that became more important. So perhaps they'll just be
replaced by more purer versions. In this case, it
could be, you know, reform UK. On the one
side that's clearly a much more pure version of,
you know, you know where Nigel Farage stands on
the EU. Yeah, he's, you know, the architect in
some ways, if you can think of it that
way, of this idea of leaving the European Union.
So perhaps there will be a replacement. I mean,
we don't know. Whether that's going to happen, but
certainly in a British context, it's quite shocking in
some ways to see reform for such a long
period of time being ahead of the two major
parties in the polls. So certainly things have been
shaken up. And so one of the reasons that
we think that that's been shaken up is because
people abandoned, or at least downgraded their partisan identity.
IN order to adopt these new identities. So there
were, so once you've done that once, and you've
said, oh, actually, I'm a conservative, but I don't
agree with David Cameron. I'm a believer, it's then
easier to take the next step and say, well,
if I'm, you know, I voted against my prime
minister and my party once, why don't I just,
you know, shift my vote choice altogether and become
a reform supporter and so on. So there was
a sort of acceleration of the weakening of partisan
identities. The final uh uh uh scenario that we
talk about is that a revival, which is this
idea of maybe Brexit comes like Brexit itself, not
just to sort of correlates, but Brexit itself is
back on the agenda, you know, are we going
to have a rejoin campaign? Are we going to,
well, so far, as we talked about the Labour
Party in particular has been quite shy of talking
about rejoining the EU. One reason for that is
of course that they still have quite a lot
of voters, supporters, or voters they would like to
attract in the next general election, who are who
are leavers, and so they, that looks like a
risky strategy in some ways, even though if we
look at the people who actually voted for them
last time, they are overwhelmingly remainers, but it seems
like maybe ignoring the issues better. So right now
we're not seeing. A big sort of mobilization around
Brexit. However, that doesn't mean it couldn't happen. And
the point about identities being sticky, that if there
was that political entrepreneurship that, that mobilized around it,
there would be people to mobilize. You know, there
would be people out there, including it probably in
the corridors of where I sit, who would be
like, oh, Yeah, hallelujah. Now we get to go
out in the street, and, you know, who would
be excited about um a rejoin campaign. There would
also be people on the other side who would
be furious, who would think, you know, our democratic
choice has been taken away, and who would therefore
be mobilized in opposition. So I'm not saying it's,
we're not saying, I think predicting, you know, predicting
is sort of a fool's game that it's going
to happen, just to say that if there were
the political entrepreneurs who wanted to take that fight,
that debate, there would be people who'd be there
alongside them fighting.
Yeah, so I have just one last question that
is sort of a more general question, even though
of course it can also apply to this Brexit
issue, but is tribal politics something that can be
overcome, and if so, how?
So I think I'm the natural pessimist, so I
should go first on this, and then you can
end on a more optimistic note. Um, BUT I
think I, I think I, yeah, I'm definitely more
of the Eyo between the two of, uh, Zar
and us. And so I think, I mean, I
just think intrinsically people are drawn to group identities.
It's emotionally satisfying to belong to a team in
politics that normally manifests itself as a party identity,
but it doesn't have to, as we've been talking
about for the last, for the last hour. Um,
AND indeed in some European countries, it's not a
party identity either. It's an ideological identity. People think
of themselves as leftists or rightists, for example, but
has the same kind of, um, structuring to politics
and to society as, as we find for Brexit
identities or many people find party identities. Whatever it
is, that thing is the thing that tends to
shape most of your political opinions and ideas. And
so politics is a team sport, uh, in my
opinion, um, in the main and. And that's not
crazy, it's, you know, it's not irrational. Most people
aren't very interested in politics. Political decisions aren't going
to affect you very much, and even if they
do, you can't do anything about it. So it's
quite sensible for people to sort of embrace this
kind of political tribalism, to adopt biased views of
the world because it's sensible to show that you're
a good group member. I'll bring you some benefits,
whereas actually the truth, um, often won't. So I
just think there's sort of an intrinsic, um. Uh,
TENDENCY for people to, uh, to go down this
kind of route. The exact nature of that, I
think, varies and, and that's, you know, kind of
what we were, I think, very interested in that,
that it had varied from the default option, if
you like, of the party identity and in Britain
over the last 10 years to this different political
identity. But the actual consequences of that are in
some ways quite similar, uh, they're just structured around
uh different identities. So I think I, I would
be sort of like, it is actually very difficult
to overcome this. I think it is a sort
of just an intrinsic feature of, of party, of
political life. But Sarah might well disagree on this,
I think, so. Or maybe not.
No, I don't think I disagree, but I think
also there's also a kind of social and political
context that might make these things more, even more
likely to happen. So I think we are, you
know, we're sort of partisan element, partisan sort of.
Not as in political party, but we do like
to belong to groups and it gives us benefit.
But on top of that, we're now, I think,
increasingly operating in worlds that are fragmented and where
we have our own, you know, we like to
surround ourselves with people or, or whether on social
media or in how we consume news, uh, or
perhaps even, you know, you know, who we interact
with who are more like ourselves in political news.
So we didn't find. You know, that much evidence
of in the book of a kind of social
media effect. But I think even in the decades
since the referendum, you know, that's become more pronounced
that, you know, when I grew up, there was
like one news channel in Denmark, everyone watched it.
So you're kind of forced, there was some kind
of, it's true. I remember when TV news came
in the news channel, and everyone thought like democracy
is over. You can't have like a second news
channel. But there was only one channel. And so
there was a kind of a level playing field.
Everyone would kind of, there was high, higher trust,
I think, and people viewed or bred sort of
similar things. There was still partisanship, but there was
some, some common denominator of what kind of information
you got. And Now we are living in a
world where we can increasingly if we want to,
and that's a great feeling. Just listen to people
who agree with us. And James and I've done
other research showing that when we do that, we
do become more polarized, we do become more intolerant.
Uh, BUT the, the psychological boost of just being
there with my Fulham supporters, oh yeah, Chelsea, they're
terrible. We're so great. The referee was Rick. It's
a great feeling. It's not as great when someone
telling you, actually, perhaps, you know, Fulham didn't play
as well as Chelsea. So you can see how
You know, I think there are some things in
the broader sort of social and political environment that
might make tribal politics provide really fertile ground for
tribal politics. However, I mean, I think that's probably
for another book, because we don't show that, but
that's, uh, that's my hunch in terms of what
might happen.
Great. So the book is again Tribal Politics How
Brexit Divided Britain. There it is in its printed
version, and of course I'm leaving a link to
it in the description of the interview. And would
you like to tell us where they can find
you and your work on the internet, perhaps starting
with you, Dr. Hoboldt.
Uh, WELL, I mean, very easy to find if
you Google me. I'm also on the Blue Sky
and LinkedIn or just on the LSE, uh, if
you want to Google my name, I'm easy to
get in touch with and always interested in talking
about these kind of subjects.
How about you, Doctor Tilly?
Uh, I'm a bit more elusive on the internet,
but I do have a web page somewhere that
the department maintains, so.
OK, I, I will add that to the description
and thank you both so much for taking the
time to come on the show. I really love
the book and it's been really nice to talk
with you about
it. Well, thank you very much for inviting us
again. Yeah,
thank you so much.
Hi guys, thank you for watching this interview until
the end. If you liked it, please share it,
leave a like and hit the subscription button. The
show is brought to you by Enlights Learning and
Development done differently. Check their website at enlights.com and
also please consider supporting the show on Patreon or
PayPal. I would also like to give a huge
thank you to my main patrons and PayPal supporters,
Perergo Larsson, Jerry Mulleran, Frederick Sundo, Bernard Seyaz Olaf,
Alex, Adam Cassel, Matthew Whittingbird, Arnaud Wolff, Tim Hollis,
Eric Elena, John Connors, Philip Forrest Connolly. Then Dmitri
Robert Windegeru Inasi Zu Mark Nevs, Colin Holbrookfield, Governor,
Michel Stormir, Samuel Andrea, Francis Forti Agnun, Svergoo, and
Hal Herz Agnon, Michel Jonathan Labrarinth, John Yardston, and
Samuel Curric Hines, Mark Smith, John Ware, Tom Hammel,
Sardusran, David Sloan Wilson, Yasilla Dezaraujo Romain Roach, Diego
Londono Correa. Yannik Punteran Ruzmani, Charlotte Blis Nicole Barbaro,
Adam Hunt, Pavlostazevski, Alekbaka, Madison, Gary G. Alman, Semov,
Zal Adrian Yei Poltontin, John Barboza, Julian Price, Edward
Hall, Edin Bronner, Douglas Fry, Franco Bartolotti, Gabriel P
Scortez or Suliliski, Scott Zachary Fish, Tim Duffy, Sony
Smith, and Wiseman. Daniel Friedman, William Buckner, Paul Georg
Jarno, Luke Lovai, Georgios Theophannus, Chris Williamson, Peter Wolozin,
David Williams, Di Acosta, Anton Ericsson, Charles Murray, Alex
Shaw, Marie Martinez, Coralli Chevalier, Bangalore atheists, Larry D.
Lee Junior. Old Eringbon. Esterri, Michael Bailey, then Spurber,
Robert Grassy, Zigoren, Jeff McMahon, Jake Zul, Barnabas Raddix,
Mark Kempel, Thomas Dovner, Luke Neeson, Chris Story, Kimberly
Johnson, Benjamin Galbert, Jessica Nowicki, Linda Brendan, Nicholas Carlson,
Ismael Bensleyman. George Ekoriati, Valentine Steinmann, Per Crawley, Kate
Van Goler, Alexander Obert, Liam Dunaway, BR, Massoud Ali
Mohammadi, Perpendicular, Janasertner, Ursula Guinov, Gregory Hastings, David Pinsov,
Sean Nelson, Mike Levin, and Jos Necht. A special
thanks to my producers Iar Webb, Jim Frank, Lucas
Stink, Tom Vanneden, Bernardine Curtis Dixon, Benedict Mueller, Thomas
Trumbull, Catherine and Patrick Tobin, John Carlo Montenegro, Al
Nick Cortiz and Nick Golden, and to my executive
producers, Matthew Lavender, Sergio Quadrian, Bogdan Kanis, and Rosie.
Thank you for all.